hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday May 9th 2016 what's going on
how you doing there fuckos Oh freckles
laying on his back trying to get rid of
the sciatica it's much better sciatica
sciatica sciatica a lot of people don't
know that was the original lyrics to
Panama you know David Lee wanted to say
you know sciatica and Eddie wanted this
and Alex wanted Panama and Michael
Anthony's like come on guys you know sup
he's having a much higher voice can we
[ __ ] just get along here and David
ended up giving in to the brothers and
that's what it next thing you know he
was on his own Rob just did judo so um
yeah my back's doing uh it's doing much
better
slowly but surely I've kind of found out
it's going to sort of work itself out if
I just don't have to sit on my [ __ ]
ass from here to Jacksonville every
other week but that's the life that I
live you know just the weirdest injury
ever usually if you're [ __ ] up sitting
down you know and resting is a good
thing this thing I just got to kind of I
get a lay down
I'm a mess I'm taking that [ __ ] I do
prone to what the [ __ ] it is some
anti-inflammatory thing I'm stretching
like a [ __ ] NHL goalie trying to get
everything all [ __ ] undone down there
but I don't know what's going on I don't
know but it is uh it is getting better
but I um I flew all the way back today
from Jacksonville had a great time and
by the way here's here's some here's
some advice for you when you're out on
the road and you're going to get a
breakfast alright unless you're in some
mom-and-pop place and you can see over
the counter you can watch you're making
your food which I don't necessarily
really like to do if you dental or
directs don't ever order scrambled eggs
I know what you're thinking why pill
would you do that because they got a
giant [ __ ] bat that they've made
scrambled eggs are the [ __ ] oatmeal
of eggs when you go to restaurants it's
just it's like the trail of zhonya it's
just that is you [ __ ] you know is
your [ __ ] eggs especially like this
morning the place where I went to
Jacksonville ate at the Chili's
restaurant in Jacksonville Florida I
know you guys you're jealous right oh my
god he gets to see everything that's so
me and for sure who murdered it all week
we ordered the the whatever the American
breakfast or something there and your
only option on the eggs was scrambled
okay now if that's the [ __ ] case that
means they got a giant vat that was
probably made I don't know how long ago
whatever the health code violation is
plus five minutes you know it's been
sitting see get the rubber [ __ ] eggs
and then bacon they just make a bunch of
[ __ ] bacon they got that sitting to
the side you know and then they had
their [ __ ] hashbrowns which you know
Dolph it was already all the whole
[ __ ] thing was already made the only
thing that really tasted good was the
biscuit so if you ever at the airport
you know or if you're go down to the
hotel you know lobby for their
continental breakfast you always never
order scrambled eggs order eggs
over-easy
get an omelet you know do something like
that where they just aren't going to
just have this [ __ ] already made or you
could do the gross [ __ ] with the syrup
but that's going to [ __ ] your whole day
up I feel I mean now like I didn't order
a big salty breakfast but for some
reason a salty breakfast as bad as it is
I can continue to function but if you
get a waffle or pancakes or french toast
to that [ __ ] you know II - we'll just
have somebody pushing a [ __ ] sleeper
hold cuz because you're going down and
you're going down early so anyway just a
little travel tip for you there
so anyways you know all this past week
lovely Nia my beautiful wife was away
and I was telling you how immaculate
I was keeping this place [ __ ] um
a culet all right and I literally like
there was no trash in any of the barrels
all the [ __ ] pillows were all puffed
up look like it was like a showroom the
living room right
I made the [ __ ] bed you know it was
spotless I wiped down my side of the
[ __ ] sink you know brush my teeth and
all that [ __ ]
spotless okay I got a car washed and
waxed filled it up with gas all of that
[ __ ] everything was done went through
all the bills got the junk mail all the
[ __ ] the recycling [ __ ]
everything I did everything right so I'm
thinking she's going to come home you
know cuz I was leaving and right as I
was leaving she was coming home she were
just missing each other right so I was
thinking when she came home she was
going to be like like Tommy you know
what I might have to bring her in for
this [ __ ] you know what I'm gonna have
to bring a ring for this hang on one
second hold on one second all right all
right so I'm back here so anyways let me
keep setting this up so my whole thing
Mia was that when you came home this
place was going to be absolutely
spotless so you'd be like oh my god
that's so nice and then also you
wouldn't feel like I was just hopeless
sap without you that always bugs me like
when women go like Jegs if they fall
apart without it's like I'm but you
never I've never said that about you nor
have I ever thought that it's I've never
come home after being away and the place
has been in shambles because you don't
know what to do oh so I don't know why
all that effort was for nothing
no but you keep holding on to some idea
of something that are you quoting an
eighty song what talking about
manspreading well I guess I got to be on
the [ __ ] couch you know I don't know
what you're so concerned about that for
like the place has never been disgusting
or gross after I've gone away so I don't
know why you have this big hang-up about
you know I don't I don't get it
you know what now I don't either well
I'm trying to think well you [ __ ]
relax you let me work through
[ __ ] oh okay sorry what's york you're
telling this story all right and then
you're out la so any adult I because I'm
told what happens so I'm [ __ ] waiting
I'm on the road on the road again and
I'm in [ __ ] Hollywood Florida right
mm-hmm
and all I'm thinking is oh the text
message I'm going to get oh it looks so
great it's so wonderful to come onto a
nice clean house it looks like a [ __ ]
showroom and what do I get I get a
[ __ ] videotape from you she's in the
pantry now evidently something went bad
in the pantry okay something didn't go
bad in the pantry is just some [ __ ]
that's going down to the pantry there's
some [ __ ] going down in the pantry so
here's the deal I'm walking on in the
pantry I'm here by myself I'm writing on
the [ __ ] show every night till 7
o'clock at night I come home my brain is
fried I come home I order a pizza I pour
a scotch I eat and then I stare at the
wall I go to bed and I get right back up
and I'm we stare at the next draft in
the next strip that's been my life so
Frank I didn't in defence of me okay the
one [ __ ] place I didn't go into so it
was a Chantry it was the pantry stop
saying I like that word I just realized
pantry pantry stuff like I don't want
you to call it's just I don't know it's
too close to panties in this whoo
I don't like good food insects to
combine okay no I know you don't like
that you see it every weird
oh that nine and a half weeks when I
know walking her with all the groceries
on her just was like look either eat or
[ __ ] not together you know so anyways so
she sends me this video she's like BB
how did you not see this right and jazz
arts [ __ ] giving me all this [ __ ] I'm
like what the [ __ ]
all right and she pans up to the top of
the [ __ ] ceiling and there was what
was it there's larvae larvae Lily a
little moths modal what so it's an
inside joke huh good inside with who
what the [ __ ] people listen at all
all right what are you mom
no yet is out of larvae there's I'm sure
there's mods and stuff because some like
if there's a flower that's been opened
and not filled up properly or grains or
cereal they'll create little moths like
if you have fruit out for too long it'll
make fruit flies so that was what was
that make fruits like it attracts them
no it creates them from that I was
talking to Tom that guy about it they
just see I don't know flies come from
apples listen yeah like if you have
fruit and stuff out to one orange on an
apple and then [ __ ] nine months later
you get a fruit fly you're like now and
if no there's no room in there that's
making an apple no built that's not what
I mean it's not worth having sex we
that's what you say you're saying I'm
not Lena I'm saying a date explicit I
don't know I'm not a [ __ ] term next
person but he was what I mean just gotta
wear dirty mops [ __ ] on those apples out
in the orchard no and they plant their
seed in there and then it comes out like
alien okay bill there's not any fruit in
the pantry okay I'm pointing at me we
have grains I'm just staring at your
crush right it's so comfortable well my
lower back is so comfortable right now
oh you know what I figured out a thing
to get for you for that but anyway we'll
get back to that but if you have grains
and cereals out exposed and like this
little closed environment where it gets
warm it produces these larvae and little
flies and moths and [ __ ] so that's what
the guy just told me he's not saying it
right well how are you saying it are you
saying I'm saying please like tell me
how you explain things and how clear it
is when you explain things okay what I
would say is like you know if you're
having a cookout and you leave food out
all of a sudden flies when ants show up
but they don't come from the food that's
what he told me I'll be keep saying they
coming from the apples and it's
confusing me it's you gotta came from
apples I said nothing about happen it
comes no I brought an alignment and I'm
here from apples I would never say it
came for you so start throwing apples
into the mix I was trying to explain to
you about grains and [ __ ] I hear you
right now I was saying it's like fruit
flies life happens
I can't even know what you're saying
because you don't listen that's why you
goddamn abd you don't listen you don't
listen and you start saying things and
you said them and you tribute them to
the other person like it's so confusing
to talk to you sometime because you
don't know it's so [ __ ] hard in
Israel how about we were just watching
The Simpsons and you watch the entire
episode and midway through it you were
like why is that happening I'm like way
to the blue space like a major plot
point that had been explained not even
five minutes earlier but you don't pay
attention how about this
how about my [ __ ] back is out and I
was in Jacksonville Florida this morning
how about that what does that have to do
with anything that we're talking about
well maybe I'm a little [ __ ] you know
not focusing on a [ __ ] cartoon okay
you're just such a baby when you hear
Apple 2 whenever you travel you [ __ ]
for like one day like over good I dunno
how you do this and then it goes right
out your [ __ ] head and then the next
next time I'm coming back off the road
you let go let's go well you know Suzie
fricassee is having a [ __ ] hoo-hah
down the [ __ ] Street you want to go to
that when I say no you flip out at me I
don't know what you're talking exactly
well you know who she is - Suzie
fricassee oh yeah mmm he's that brother
that's nothing
all right so whatever so she comes home
and evidently there's some sort of bug
horror movie and you know how what
infestation infestation you know how the
ladies react they don't like insects you
know what I mean they don't like any
we're not have enjoyed that way walk the
way men don't like cats those [ __ ]
pigs
there's nothing better than a cool cat I
like a cool cat that chills and lays are
[ __ ] son yeah you know I like my all
right now I'm cruising up on you yeah I
don't like that I'm going to practicing
killing it
you just look over in there staring at
you from corner now then they stop and
try and play it off I don't like I don't
like to say stand on your chest in the
morning right waking you up I don't like
they [ __ ] in a box and then you got to
pick it up it's just too much too much
Cleo shit's just outside all those are
but we all got to pick it up
I know but I don't have to it's not in
the house chair I mean if you get a [ __ ]
in the house go in the toilet I think
some people can train their cats to [ __ ]
in the toilet I don't know how but well
I can tell you how they can't
communicate with other human beings so
they put all their energy into yeah like
they got like that gift they have like a
like a Asperger oh I see what you mean
Asperger's what cat with some sort of um
what's that thing they're always talking
about nowadays after them autism the
other autistic with people but okay this
is communicate with the cat just stop
what did make you like play an
instrument not with no diagnosis of the
mental illness assist Elsa Scott like
that yes we talked about it again are
you gonna get angry tweets I'm not
mocking mocking any of that I'm making
fun of people that put you can't [ __ ]
and say anything anymore everybody gets
all worried
oh I know yeah I do benefits for all of
those things all of those things I know
about my free [ __ ] on your best for
all the black ah I remember when things
were funny
oh it was so simple back in the day yeah
it was you could chain you say Sharon no
and everything what can jerk off didn't
have some way they could just spout
about up [ __ ] annoyed they are but
everything else is fine as long as it
doesn't come around to my world can I
just ask what this situation is here
with the ziplock bag what about and how
you're keeping your equipment store yeah
Bill's got this cord and the little
foamy part that you put on a the
windscreen the windscreen and a couple
of batteries and an old ziplock bag
that's ripped and just doesn't even zip
anymore
right so I'm just wondering why
basically because it still holds the
things and if I just throw that thing
out another one's going to break and
then that thing right there is probably
going to end up on the nose of a
porpoise and it's not gonna be able to
eat it's going to die because everything
ends up in the ocean yeah you know they
say that put litter in its place it's
like the second eldest ship that you
throw out they saying you don't pollute
we
all pollute did you stop us do you take
the fear out of this like I was having
an idea that good I mean do I take it on
the road you're just going to be like
have a look about something that you
don't really know about us at all I mean
I don't really feel it like a charm I'm
not getting anything
so you take this on the road with you
yes all right I could maybe get you a
nice never helped leather satchel really
you got a skin a [ __ ] cow because I
already already have one it'll last
longer than putting it in this
ridiculous thing that's now we're gonna
buy our grade
what's this that thinking that thing
won't biodegrade clout that thing will
be here somewhere in the dirt somewhere
for hundreds of [ __ ] years after
we're gone saying you can have a nice
way to carry your things that doesn't
look like you know don't exactly want it
use for sandwiches what is your
fascination with just like buying [ __ ]
what do you mean fascination with buying
shape session I mean look at this look
at this like you're carrying this thing
and I really wish you guys could see the
ziplock bag right now it's a mess a man
of your stature should not be carrying
around your podcast equipment in an oil
man what are you Griffin is it block
that a man of my stature [ __ ] two
seconds ago I was a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
can even ask now cuz you to shave from
me day so who do you like tonight who we
got well my night Louis Blues meet me in
st. Louie Louie versatile the Dallas
Stars formerly the Minnesota North Stars
are these hockey teams yes they are
oh if they're not like the kings or the
Bruins Donna let me know oh yeah what
are your feelings about the kings in the
Bruins well if it came down to it I
would be a Bruins fan because I'm from
Boston oh you just saying they gonna
root for ya but that was the rest of
them I don't know those are my two
tealight I like both teams but I just I
started pulling for the Blues because
the Blues have been in the league since
1960 was getting to because the Bruins
didn't make the playoffs so I was like
alright I got to pick somebody and I'm
not going to jump on the Blackhawks and
kings
bandwagon because they were always in it
so I'm going to go for an underdog I was
like well the Blues they've been around
since 1967
so the Minnesota North Stars but the
people in Dallas haven't been rooting
that long but I really like the players
and [ __ ] I like I like Dallas but I've
ever um I'm babbling over here look a
little bit yes saint-lo they're going to
be relaxed is there going to be a
campaign that we can go to because I
really enjoyed going to that those two
kingpins we went to yeah that they got
bounced up there done what do you mean
bounced down they they got beat by the
San Jose Sharks oh so they're not in it
it's over so for them the Stanley Cup
Playoffs they go they got they lost in
the first round what about the Brewers
we didn't make it we were well we we
overt well we overachieved throughout
the year because at least as far as I
was concerned but garner would do [ __ ]
my but I mean with the players that we
had and everything we got rid of I
thought we would be trying to figure out
who the [ __ ] everybody was for half the
season and then maybe you know I don't
know what about the Toronto Blue Jays
what happened was we were going to be
making the playoffs everybody was all
bunched together we look at [ __ ]
third seat then we had a West Coast trip
and we got a [ __ ] asses kicked and it
all went away and I flier and Red Wings
fans talk [ __ ] about you know how you
didn't make the playoffs and they both
got the right there Fred in the first
[ __ ] round so I enjoyed that
okay well the Toronto Blue Jays is that
a hockey team no that's baseball
oh it serrano Maple Leafs the Maple
Leafs got the first pick in the draft
our afters are they hot Hawk is you know
basketball team oh Jesus keep-keep
saying this [ __ ] you know and I'll do it
you and you you pick something else that
I don't know anything about we'll see
who's more right what are you into that
you know about I just say that question
you know about I know fashion okay go
ahead oh Jesus what's the name of the
guy what's fun of fat people he used to
be fat ah is that that's that's not
Alexander Wang is it now is that Michael
Richards is it Michael
michael kors no she's German Paul
Mitchell and he is the head of a very
very like the most famous fashion house
in the world it's not for Sachi because
he got shot by that guy
yes no it's not a Chanel because I was a
chicken she's dead right but she has an
apartment in Paris that you can go into
it you're skinny enough right but your
your clothes you're getting that Chanel
is right Chanel's the right fashion
house person who you're talking about is
the head creative director for Chanel he
looks like a war criminal right you
German there you go and why would they
work for a little dia
because they lost he would add just as
many people going to [ __ ] Nuremberg I
really would have okay Dresden Karl
Lagerfeld [ __ ] remember when we saw him
and the last time we were in Paris in
the cab and I started freaking out
because I saw Carl all that all right
walking down the street in Paris and I
thought really cool-looking dude man
vampire looking this vampire fire war
from an old Queen looking dude yeah
pretty much
that's him all right name a sports team
go ahead um I'll name one of you tell me
what it is the Yellow Jackets somebody
what to this mix that up yellow check I
feel like that was a high school I feel
like that was a [ __ ] fusion band what
about wait a minute no no wasn't it
that's not like Wake Forest or stuff
that's a college basketball team some
sort of jacket talk of Grizzlies yeah
what Grizzlies Toronto Michigan it's
someplace cold that would have grizzly
bears right so it's not going to be a
swather and Gooden good guess but they
moved they were naturally interviewer
initially in the backcourt okay
Midwestern kind of thing they were
initially in Vancouver and then they
went to another in Memphis oh that's a
nice question for some dumb reason they
kept the name kind of like when the New
Orleans Jazz moved to Utah the whitest
[ __ ] place ever Utah Jazz like you'll
never see any jazz or hear any Jam and
you
yeah I wouldn't think so this are no
jazz clubs and Utah yeah it's like the
New Orleans Mormons nor with Mormon I
like that name better um all right well
we enjoyed you here Nia oh I'm done I
don't know you found saying Oh God
holla good I know I gotta call her back
um are you done with me are you wrapping
up the podcast did you answer questions
no but you can come back to that are
just kind of tired so I'm gonna leave oh
nice reversal I kicked you off and they
do like now let me come back and they
tell me to go [ __ ] myself you know what
I enjoyed it I respect that so I just
came on to total RV's larvae larvae and
then leave a get out of here so I can
straighten out my legs and [ __ ] get
my pie feel like Kennedy right are you
even able to do a podcast in the upright
position anymore um this is why I
married you this is the type of
compassion I could have come to expect
for me you're such a [ __ ] baby I cut
my way through all of this [ __ ] I never
I never see doctors I don't take
medicine that's because you're dumb it's
not gonna show off it's because are dumb
Wilson also he's awake don't go to the
hospital they don't go to doctors
they'll take medicine no you're dumb we
have advances in our society and you
don't I am tough but I'm tougher than
you you're a baby so fine be tough all
you want but like be smart and tough go
to the doctor if you're so tough go to
the doctor in here what they have our
net point in like I have to school
special
yeah well I'm getting there beefs up I
know Anna doctor in hearing what they
have to say that's real toughness that's
real talk that's real talk son
all right I'm out of here Nene out sorry
I got to hide I enjoyed when you come on
I like to miss you baby huh all right
kid okay huh you heard me
listen I went out you know you know I
don't go to [ __ ] doctors and all that
[ __ ] why because doctors they practice
medicine they practice on you they don't
have [ __ ] down and one of the one of the
things that they still don't know a lot
of practice but it's not like they don't
mean it like they're practicing like you
sitting here practicing drums you know
that's not the same thing they went to
medical school I understand that so why
are you you like taking that word so
literally have you ever seen Lars Ulrich
play life and practices yeah he [ __ ] up
all the time with Metallica oh my god
Nia yeah I'm telling you that's what it
means you practice medicine and then you
learn off of other people just look how
much better hair plugs have got look how
much better they're getting with the
[ __ ] you know cutting party I out and
then you can see better you told me
you're going to go to a doctor to figure
out what was happening with your leg
okay so I noticed I know you saw Anika I
know you think you know what it is but
can you please go to a doctor no it
doesn't become a chronic issue I
finished it and then when you're you
know 50 which is can I can I finish far
away
can I finish you can see you can have
some sort of handle on it yeah one of
the things that they know the least
about is the back okay and I'm just I'm
just not going to just go to a [ __ ]
chiropractor I'm going to find somebody
you know who has a good reputation if
not just [ __ ] opening people up like
a fly it isn't fine because I wasn't
done talking you always jump in because
you're suggesting that I just want you
to go to some random-ass clinic I was
just joking around
I was joking around well I'm holding you
to this because you said you were going
to do it so are you going to do it um I
don't know sound pretty good I don't
like doing it this I don't like go to
the doctor way I don't like going to the
[ __ ] mall I just the whole idea going
over there parking and just a whole
[ __ ] thing I know I think you feel we
shall make sure you show up 15 minutes
before up yeah y'all be there
see you then I know but once it's done
it's done you know my first show in
Hollywood Florida there was a couple of
ladies in the front row well asking if
you were there because they needed
relationship in place oh yeah you know
yeah they were like how come we don't
have boyfriends now they didn't say this
that's what they said some actually
wrote me and asked me about
you proposing and actually that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to talk about this
email I got should we do it today or
should we do it no who the [ __ ] is
writing you and how the [ __ ] are they
writing you because they write mics
because of my website tender-headed
films.com so they were writing me
because remember I was going to do a
podcast all those years ago and I just
never did it
no they wrote this whole thing about how
did you get a guy who was so
anti-marriage to propose and all that
kind of stuff and how did it happen and
did I propose no I did not propose he'll
propose to me and all that stuff then
what you do I keep I've read it down I
just excuse me I wore him down
no no see this is why we have to talk
about it because that's some [ __ ] oh
we do that out of it I got a joke will
you [ __ ] relax down you love me you
missed me you told you larvae story know
one thing about show business is you
leave them wanting more
so get your [ __ ] cute ass out of here
all right goodbye
I want to talk about that sorry that I
want to end oh we all want to do things
in life beat it goodbye
hit the road jack don't you come back no
mo no mo no hit the road Nene yeah so
that's what I came up to she [ __ ]
shows me this big goddamn thing about
all the [ __ ] we granted them as much
as I'm going to [ __ ] it was a bunch of
[ __ ] larvae I swear to god she says
that comes from apples and flowers the
flower and flower being left out in
grains what happened you know if you
agree with her you can go [ __ ]
yourselves how about that alright let's
read a little advertising here for this
week shall we oh my goodness MGMT
watches you know it's been a few weeks
now since they started advertising
movement watches boxes and oh I don't
understand this copy as promised the
quality of these watches are there for
an awesome price in the style department
the compliments that you'll get wearing
these things are really unbelievable you
know what I'm do I got to start this
over again this is
I'm doing is they keep [ __ ] having me
say that I cracked open these boxes and
I'm [ __ ] wearing one right now and
I'm not so it [ __ ] up all the copy
alright I will read what you write but
I'm not going to start lying saying I
have on your [ __ ] underwear your
watch is when I don't listen these are
let me start over again so they don't
hear that part cuz they only I don't
listen that [ __ ] part they just
listen to the read alright unless one of
you [ __ ] rats me out on Twitter like
the [ __ ] G edgar Hoover's everybody's
acting like nowadays alright MV MT
watches if you haven't had a chance to
experience how a movement watch fits
around your wrist well god damn it this
is your chance movement watches start at
just $95 see when movement cut out the
middleman with huge big brand markups
the price of a stylus watch finally got
affordable imagine that a watch with
department store quality for a fraction
of the price movement has grown
organically purely by supporters like
you so join their more than 1 million
social media followers and get a
movement watch today please fill out MP
MP okay go to mV Mt Michael Victor
Michael Tom watches dot-com / / and
they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase purchase that's M VMT watches
comm / / alright hellix or helix what is
it about buying a mattress that leaves
you feeling violated just that's not a
good word to use with a mattress is it
the pushy salespeople the fake
Presidents Day sales or the fact you
know you'll regret what you bought as
you do the walk of shame out of the
mattress store because you get violated
well what kind of sex offender has shown
you your sheets
hellix helix those days are over thanks
to helix sleep well you can buy a
mattress online customized for you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
go to helix sleep calm answer a few
simple questions and HELOCs creates your
custom sleep profile to build you the
perfect mattress the result our
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall sleep your mattress will arrive
at your door in about a week and
shipping is always 100% free you'll have
100 nights to try it out and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and you you get a hundred percent
refund that's pretty cool huh it's
almost three months it's over three
months
no questions asked it's like it never
happened if you do like the new helix
mattress keep it then your dignity
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes are all talking about helic sleep
go to helix sleep calm slash / and get
$50 off your order
that's helic sleep calm / / hey helix
sleep calm / / one of those
pronunciations is right all right Dollar
Shave Club everybody oh my god look
who's back
Dollar Shave Club dollarshaveclub.com is
a special offer for new members who
joined today you'll get a free month of
the executive razor when you buy a tube
of doctor carving shave butter I swear
to god it used to be easy shaped butter
this is the first time they've ever done
something like this and once you try
dollarshaveclub.com you'll become a
proud member like millions of others one
reason is because they deliver amazing
rate as razors right to your door for a
third of the price of what the greedy
razor corporations charge that means
when you join Dollar Shave Club you can
afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want which feels fantastic
you'll get a first-class shave when you
use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet another reason is their
doctor KOB easy using it with the
executive razor the blade just glides
gently for the smoothest shave ever dr.
carver shave butter isn't your average
shave cream it's a unique conditioning
formula with high-quality natural
ingredients leaving your skin feeling
unbelievably smooth and soft and right
now new members who buy a to of shea
butter get the executive razor for
absolutely free they've never done this
before take advantage of it
or you'll regret it for the rest of your
life and it's only available by going to
doctors dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / / and lastly but
certainly not least Lee our old friends
at stamps
as America celebrates the National Small
Business Week this week
stamps.com wants to honor not only its
over 600,000 small business customers
stamps.com also wants to extend an
invitation to every small business
throughout the nation to help their
business succeed by reducing or
eliminating wasteful trips to the post
office
stamps.com knows that one of your most
valuable resources as a small business
is time you can't waste it making
constant goddamn trips down to the post
office for mailing and shipping
that's why stamps.com brings all the
services of the post office right to
your desk by imprint official US postage
for any letter any package any class of
mail using your computer and printer
over 600,000 small businesses are
already using stamps calm and you know
what you should too I use stamps calm
anytime and send it on any stupid
posters whatever [ __ ] I'm trying to
sell after my shows if I can figure it
out so can you right now you sign up for
stamps calm and use my last name bird
for this special offer four week trial
plus a one hundred and ten dollar bonus
offer that includes postage and stitch
and a digital scale don't wait go to
Stan's calm before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in bird that
stamps comm enter burr alright and with
that it's over come on come on now
delete close the window and on to the
rest of the [ __ ] um at the worst
[ __ ] gave us a good guy but I had a
bad cab driving way back from the
[ __ ] airport
use one of those one of those people
that can't keep a consistent speed you
know so they make you carsick and what
was hilarious was he was driving a Prius
and the way he was driving this thing I
would be surprised if he was getting a
count it eight miles per gallon he just
kept doing that man just stomp and glide
I got just amazing me some people like
how they cannot hear you can't hear the
engine you know you can't hear the
[ __ ] RPMs going through the roof you
don't understand that is wasting fuel I
know you know how bad those cabbies get
[ __ ] over you think that he would be
concerned about something you think if
you drove for a [ __ ] living you'd
have a
understanding of how a [ __ ] engine
works
[Music]
it was so [ __ ] annoying it actually
it just kind of just became funny and he
was a really nice guy but um I know some
people like it's almost it's like that
driving with a fake foot you know or a
mechanical foot like the prototype and
you know it's either on or off there's
no consistency of speed this guy he just
kept going up to like 65 70 miles an
hour and then glide back down to like
you know 50 - of course I'm looking at
my [ __ ] phone so I'm starting to get
sick say you know it was a [ __ ] show an
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] show oh you know
when I went to Florida by the way I
landed in Miami
every time I landed to Miami I
immediately start seeing all these
beautiful women every time I go there I
just hear Tony Montana's voice going the
city is like one big [ __ ] waiting to
get fought and I was trying to bait me
into those two women that was sitting in
the front row to get into that [ __ ]
conversation but she didn't buy the bait
he didn't take the bait because they
were like why don't we have boyfriends
you know and you should have seen him
because you I don't know because you
guys are you know wearing any clothes
let's that'd be the one thing as
beautiful as you are no guy wants to put
up with that you got to walk down the
street like some overprotective dog is
keeping everybody away everybody one of
them was barely wearing a shirt granted
I wasn't complaining for where I was
standing from but I mean it just seemed
kind of obvious you know what I mean you
got it well you got to cover up the
goods a little bit I mean I would say
that's a Madonna I don't know if she's
currently dating somebody right now but
Madonna is in [ __ ] unbelievable shape
for her age and if she would just put on
something elegant you know what I mean
instead of rolling around with half a
[ __ ] [ __ ] lip hanging out I don't
know why she does it
she said something late now that she did
yet another tiger old [ __ ] career has
been like one big publicity stunt after
another you know I'm wearing a pope a
wedding dress but I'm fingering myself
at the [ __ ] awards show right you
know right from
there and then Oh it's Jesus but he's
african-american and now I'm trying to
[ __ ] them it's just paint-by-numbers
shock and what's funny is I actually
like her music I just keep you know
that's actually I threw out my back
doing that Molly Ringwald dance anyway
yeah and then she goes on Letterman she
says [ __ ] fifty thousand times she does
stand-up on The Tonight Show is just one
big [ __ ] thing after another so her
latest one well she showed up to a movie
theater now move out movie premiere or
whatever the [ __ ] she I don't who the
[ __ ] knows what it was you know some
fundraiser to get toothbrushes to some
[ __ ] guards cuz they can play so she
shows up and she literally has her
titties in her ass up like a see-through
dress and she of course says well what
I'm doing is I'm challenging the
boundaries and of what you know of
course women you know gonna drag all
that [ __ ] and then it's like no
you're 57 okay nobody wants to look at
that okay like at my age I am I am
Welling to put on a [ __ ] sport coat
nobody wants to see it it's just uh yeah
you're not pushing any boundaries it's
just it's a you know you having a little
bit of a midlife crisis I think she
looks [ __ ] great but she looked way
better after she [ __ ] hill you know
put on spells [ __ ] dress [ __ ] you
don't I don't know but then again I saw
Iggy Pop and he wasn't wearing his shirt
but I don't find guys aren't like
attractive it was just sort of funny to
me not funny I just was just him not
giving a [ __ ] so I guess if she just
said look I don't give a [ __ ] I just
felt like havin my ass and titties
hanging out I wouldn't have a problem
with that but but the fact that she's
sitting there trying to say that no no
wait a minute I think she might be right
maybe she is right hey
there's a chance I might become
enlightened and understand the saw
tomorrow
until she comes here I'll sing sing some
of my favorite songs by her bad boy no
bad girl home by six
hey pick up the mic I got a question for
you now you want me back yeah that's
like that Street joke I told you right
watch when I heard Jackie two joke mento
the one about the gorilla no the one
with the [ __ ] the married guy he's
walking out of the house and his wife's
yelling AB don't get the [ __ ] out of
here
get the [ __ ] out I never want to see you
again
he's walking when she goes I hope you
dial a long slow miserable death he
turns around he goes ah what now you
want me back that's two glasses stupid
joking just reminding me that anyway
school I could have told it better but I
got it I just got off playing Jackie D
jump Frank Elsa wait I um all right so
Madonna recently bought an mm-hmm um she
showed up at some [ __ ] you know raise
awareness thing I don't know what it was
it was a carpet she showed up and she
had a butt cheeks out and her titties
out okay this was the mess hall that
happens every year in New York City and
that's for the Mets yes it is like oh
man but it's just for one of them I know
it's for the [ __ ] Museum yeah the
hacky date every [ __ ] person in that
20s goes on in New York and Madonna
let's go to a museum big gala only the
creme that a crab darling I invited Oh
so Ralph Lauren pretends to follow me
sniffs her but on the way down from so
what happens what you know super rich
people they're all freaks
aren't they I guess wasn't at the point
eyes wide shut
I don't know what the point of I sweat
[ __ ] what what happened was Stanley
Kubrick died he died happily - I saw a
great [ __ ] movie on the plane called
the insiders it's a movie made by some
Korean director man it was [ __ ]
phenomenal yeah really enjoyed it okay
had one of the best
could fight scenes I've seen because the
guy was missing a hand mm-hmm
you know so he had to like [ __ ] you
know everybody knew what hand he was
throwing right it was multiple attackers
it was the [ __ ]
I almost gave it a standing ovation on
the plane if it was pretty 9/11 I could
have done it but I started to do and
they're like sorry sir waiting hustle I
had to sit down it's another freedom
lost so anyways so [ __ ] but Donna
shows up uh-huh yeah sorry
okay so she says that she's trying to
[ __ ] push the boundaries about
whatever the [ __ ] section that type
of thing yeah okay so I was going like
dump come on you 57 don't want to see me
without a shirt on grand she's in better
shape than I but like you know I'm in
must my sport coat yes like you covered
up their freckles right what I'm saying
is you're in your sport coat you yeah
yeah yeah you get to a certain point
you're getting your forties and stuff
like that women dress elegantly and men
dress like gentlemen yeah another word
like that yeah you cover up you know the
[ __ ] battle scars of what you've been
through okay
do any [ __ ] wine and cheese plates
know what I'm saying is so I'm saying
the part but Donna just put on a nice
dress she could look really elegant yeah
that's not really her time yeah I know I
know but you know something it's like II
but look even whose can do Michael
Jackson if he was still alive to UT the
short pants with the glitter socks like
come on dude some point you got to
update the look what is it what is your
point with this whole Madonna thing
that's all I want man I was saying that
but then I was like wait a minute but
when I saw Iggy Pop with no shirt on I
thought it was badass that daddy didn't
give a [ __ ] so that that's that's
[ __ ] so I should be actually
applauding Madonna
Wow look at you see that that's not
that's not nice okay I was gonna say you
were like wow look at you you're really
not as dumb so my apologies to Madonna
ah you like I'm showing up on behind
take it look at my [ __ ] 57 year-old
Katie pk7 she's my age would 10 she 10
years were 10 years apart
so she's sixties wait what John I'm 57
years a week yes she is
she was born to stay here as Prince oh
[ __ ]
no semillas Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson was 58 Prince was 50 antique
Madonna was 58 I never know and that was
like in 1957 oh my god you're right
she's gonna be 58 right had no idea and
nagas yeah she'll be 58 yeah so 1958 as
far as music goes was kind of like 1943
1943 was Janis Joplin Jimi Hendrix and
Jim Morrison all born 1943 and then they
all died in 1970 and then people started
to understand drugs and you know bring a
jump rope on the road and measures
becoming a vegan so now they live longer
Michael made it to 50 prints made to 57
but Donna's still going okay all of them
in their own way kind of went on stage
with their ass hanging out right okay
where are you going nowhere I gotta roll
up an hour and time I gotta [ __ ] I
want to do some questions here okay so
you brought me in to show me that you've
evolved in seeing your own no I was
trying to humble stay there a second if
it wasn't aging women and showing their
bodies yeah and you know double standard
also works with women the way they look
at guys in certain situations so as you
guys aren't like perfect no one no one
is claiming to be perfect okay well the
media just seems to cover your
complaints and then this [ __ ] when will
you ever have a voice uh-huh
thank God you have this podcast I don't
no one would hear me okay
listen man you don't understand the
world doesn't live with me they don't
have the privilege of living with me the
way you do so I need to do this once a
week that's a [ __ ] beautiful watch
who got you that you did that's right
[ __ ] really responds to stinky German
from last week so this poor bastard
he's German right and so he lives in
Germany he's old school
he didn't leave and try to be like hey I
wasn't part of that hit listing right
Brian teased oh yeah his grandparents
said you know I don't know if it's me
but this guy's make it a lot of sense so
so because of the mistakes of his
forefathers and mothers the gods have
cursed him that he just sort of smells a
little musty and he's teeth try
showering it as all this [ __ ] he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] to do so evidently
this visit this other musty guy formerly
musty guy heard about this okay doesn't
he look into his diet yeah we talked
about that and how it ptosis maybe have
a [ __ ] and a sinus infection I don't
know what but he just likes me just
smell bad no matter how much he showers
so this guy says yeah he wears deodorant
yeah it was quite it's quite a mystery
boy I'll tell you this I'll tell you
whoa this person didn't respond to this
this is a formerly musty person so I
hope this helps the sauerkraut oh whoa
that is my best [ __ ] fun ever I'm
sorry but that [ __ ] was great all right
that was fun sound good that was good
thank you no sugar all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna
he said I'm gonna and keep this simple
because we all know of your reading
issues what I admittedly have I've been
a fan for years but this is the first
time I feel the need to chime in on
something
last week you read a question from a
German guy that had a musty body odor
and did not know what to do about it
he said growing up I dealt with the same
[ __ ] that poor sap is going through
I always smelled musty I could not wash
it away no matter how often I showered
this is brutal I feel bad these people I
tried everything and finally realized it
was it was antiperspirant for some weird
reason my body reacted when I put it on
and I smelled musty I actually stopped
wearing deodorant for a few weeks in the
winter so I did not smell like a
complete savage after that period of
time I began wearing deodorant only
skipping all brands with antiperspirant
happily the stinky musty odor went away
hope this works
you stinky [ __ ] loves the podcast your
comedy and emphasis for family and go
[ __ ] yourself yeah so basically what I
got from that is maybe his body is
having reaction to something that he is
using I don't know because your body
should sweat it's the way to keep you
cool right that's the whole point of
sweating so antiperspirant I know maybe
people who sweat excessively they don't
want to be sweating through their
clothes or something so I don't know but
it sounds like that person should go to
a doctor well they haven't been able to
figure out what's going on and he's in
Germany too and those guys don't [ __ ]
around over there they're very efficient
yeah sure oh yeah
cars the trades the rocket side trick
you know everybody could just forgive
them for that one crazy 10-year period I
think they got a little sideways
still never I'll never live it though no
you can't sorry you know what it's on
video nothing like you know other
countries can do [ __ ] and it happened
before like it's certain something that
happened in 1915 that we are we see
advertised my vote dear bill on Capitol
Hill I don't know you're talking now
well you should you know what if there
was movie cameras around you would movie
yep motion picture things have you ever
heard of Berman supreme he's been on I
don't I don't believe that this is
somebody's name I'm gonna look this up
before you guys make a fool of me which
is not hard to do why not you read it
first cuz then I start commenting and
then halfway through I realize it's a
prank phone call Berman dream it's
coming up
it's Berman supreme Verma supreme is an
American performance art artists and
activists who has run as a candidate in
very low various local states okay let
me see what this what's up with this guy
okay
I never heard of this guy he's been on
the ballot in New Hampshire and his
platform has a lot to do with dental
health he also has a plan in place for
the zombie apocalypse which involves
setting up thousands of treadmills to
put the zombies on to help power the New
World
he wears a giant boot on his head oh
I've seen this [ __ ] guy the boot
that's right and carries around a rubber
toothbrush here's an article on him he
also has promised free ponies for
everyone oh so he's a whack job I don't
know if he's a whack job because that's
a really funny joke though the zombies
on the treadmill are you looking them up
or you next thing I was looking at
Madonna thought of okay we back here and
we know we moved on we moved on but I
just was still looking at photos I'm
here Papa don't preach army trouble t
you know and hopper dope you know any
new Madonna songs and I feel I just said
I sorry because I did my [ __ ] I
didn't even hear your vocal warm-ups
yeah this was not a good look at the Met
Ball it was just i yeah Oh
ladies can we you stick together first
of all a woman is laughing at that I
just got something up to you all right
yeah home but no it's not I'm not being
catty she just it's just so thirsty it's
just I don't
and I love Madonna but this is just too
much are you done yeah I'm done I'm sure
her kids enjoy uh wife's family is a
bunch of dramatic babies oh god you're
the baby here we go hey Bill I'm sick of
this election
I hope Trump wins I know he's a jerk but
I hate Hillary I think bernie is a nice
guy without a clue he says a lot of
great things but he's going to raise
taxes he talks about making college free
but his taxes will make it huh nothing
is free yeah yeah that's never going to
happen but I think you know free health
care nothing's not free again somebody's
got to [ __ ] pay for he talks about
making college free but his taxes will
make it harder for people like me to pay
my student loans
I make 95 grand a year I have a kid on a
grand in student loans between me and my
wife we live comfortably but if you take
another 2,500 to 4,000 dollars for me a
year I will feel it yeah definitely
I am already only netting 60 what is the
[ __ ] is all of this yeah what's the plan
the family is a bunch of dramatic babies
all right blah okay so we're getting
we're getting - is grandma here
somewhere I'm not opposed to giving
money to help people who need it but
when is enough enough a trillion dollars
on dumb [ __ ] every year and you need
more from me [ __ ] off Bernie I love how
he's blaming Bernie you know it Bernie
didn't create the [ __ ] situation I'm
just trying to get us out of it I guess
I don't know if it's going to work I
don't think I mean I don't know people
work with the guy but oh god what a
[ __ ] decision this year so I make
this point to my wife my wife's family I
didn't yell
I didn't say [ __ ] off Bernie I just said
I don't think we the people should have
to give more money if they're wasting
the money they already get well my
wife's family lost their [ __ ] they said
that I'm selfish and that if I vote for
Trump I'm endorsing hate and greed and
fascism really question mark they
endorsed Obama and I have a problem with
him faithfully blowing up kids and
wedding parties with drones
why doesn't that make them hateful they
then went on to talk about for 30
minutes about hate and how this they
were scared about what would happen to
the country and they're scared about how
children will grow up in a country with
and I quote Hitler - the concentration
camps I told him that comparing an
egomaniac to Hitler is unfair to the
victims of the Holocaust it trivializes
the actual evil of hit Hitler and
embodied her mother and father were both
taken aback and said that my way of
thinking could potentially be dangerous
to their grandchildren what period the
[ __ ] period is going period on period
well you dope yeah you [ __ ] opened up
I never [ __ ] mouth about politics time
to talk about no yes and he's young he
doesn't help
that's what now you know yeah and how
did you learn how did you learn and how
did I learn by bringing it up by doing
that yet this is advanced Mary yeah you
know you can't talk about politics and
religion and [ __ ] like that those I'm
going to say you got it got really
heated right before they said that [ __ ]
well you can't and also you just yeah I
don't know you gotta be if you really
are going to vote for Trump I just I
think there's only certain sections of
the United States where you could say
that where you'll get a yeah I get it oh
will tell me more about your opinion I
feel like if you say you know what Fox
is I'm voting for Trump most people are
going to be like are you [ __ ] kidding
me so I'm not surprised at that but no
yeah you've got a lot of [ __ ] when I was
I made fun of them would uh you know I
got some [ __ ] for it for making fun of
Trump's yeah from who people who support
Trump oh okay yes believe it or not
there's people that say well I I know it
has a lot more than I thought remember
when we was first talking about running
and we're both like this is never gonna
happen this is a jobs ridiculous and now
here we are and he's like the only
Republican left standing so I mean I
guess I underestimated him yeah he likes
the letter public attorney
he's like the Leicester City Apollo
politician time but here's the thing
though I famine but I think like you
know Hillary
it's the [ __ ] devil because she's
acting like she gives a [ __ ] and she's
you know she's one of those Bilderberg
people I don't like her I like Bernie
out of all of them I like Bernie Sanders
I just don't think anybody's gonna
[ __ ] work for well the California
primary is coming up so he's not thrown
in the towel Bernie I have to you know
that info with an eye and I am a bully
here agai I have to vote for a person
that I feel is actually truly gives a
[ __ ] about regular people and that would
be him whether he's going to be
successful or not and I know what a lot
of people say like oh you're gonna put
him I've always voted for the [ __ ]
third wheel every [ __ ] goddamn time
well when the primary happens we gotta
vote for him that's the only way that
he'll listen I don't have to do anything
that you say but I don't know what I'm
going to do so basically his this guy's
in law you know we just didn't need him
you know we just did we just did what
this guy did we just [ __ ] talked to
politics and gave endorsements to
Bernice and we should have done that I
still have made up my mind that I'm
going to do that why are we we're giving
indoors just by talking about it by
saying that you're gonna do it well we
like that guy that thought we're like
those those people that you see on
Facebook and they go hey you know me I
pretend to be a doctor on a soap opera
and I think this is who you should vote
for I apologize for that people I try
not to say that and I know we're we're
not endorsing anybody weird bowl bus is
leaving okay what I'm endorsing a nice
[ __ ] cold Budweiser when I sit down
to watch Game five that's what I
wondered what is what if you want to
know he's just sort of like what the
hell now my now my in-laws don't want me
to have children with my wife because
they think I'm evil and they're gonna
I'm gonna raise a little evil from my
thing about Trump is his [ __ ] lack of
compassion for [ __ ] people when you
sit there and say take his coat he has
violent people up like that was he says
but most he's really really awful things
but the thing I like about him is he
lets me know that they actually count
the votes because no super rich people
want that [ __ ] guy and I always
thought for years my conspiracy theories
like they don't count these [ __ ]
thing they do it's pretty [ __ ] close
they put the money on both horses and
then this
can find but the fact that he's actually
doing well
he's speaking a lot of people out there
needs I am going to build a wall he's
going to have the people he's walling in
pay for it telling him he's talking mad
[ __ ]
I don't know I feel like all those years
of watching The Apprentice and the
Celebrity Apprentice are now coming back
when he tried to find CEO for a company
that doesn't exist it's all coming back
to bite me in the ass I've been
supporting in this whole entire time I'm
partly to blame for this [ __ ] so
what is this cool look you can't be a
boy what is this kid saying what is this
point he just is no you're just saying
what what the [ __ ] so I was we just now
you will not talk about politics anymore
around your in-laws oh yeah tell you
that much they said looking forward to
seeing you in Dublin myself and some
friends will be coming from Belfast well
I'm going to be doing Belfast too so you
don't yeah you don't you need to do that
yeah we're putting together the dates
look I'm definitely doing Dublin
definitely doing Belfast exciting yeah
I'm doing a little 10-day tour over
there because skin it's not a good time
to go to Scandinavia this time of year
because they actually have sunlight it's
warm out okay so yes when I usually
quote because they're going to want to
be outside okay yeah but oh yeah if you
go into sunburn it's already don't go to
movies and stuff still though I would
imagine just cuz it's sunlight most the
time doesn't mean all right why would I
listen to the promoters over there I'll
look right all right what's happening
I'm gonna go it's going to be happening
and did you like think it's going to
start on the 31st and it's going to go
into August very excited about that
exciting things are happening I love
Ireland you know I love the people of
Ireland Hey look who you with over Sato
face and shelter advice with neighbors
mostly German Oh Almighty Billy buying
she don't even know that because I have
never done me whole uh but you've always
you're always lack of more German than
Irish cuz I am German Irish Catholic
doesn't like gesture doesn't get any
wider doesn't get doesn't get any wider
almighty Billy ball bangs all right vice
with neighbors question I live in an
apartment complex here
in the lovely state of Oklahoma and I
have this neighbor who lets her dog out
on her balcony every morning somewhere
between the hours of 4:00 and 5:00 a.m.
the dog barks aggressively for hours
afterwards of course it wakes me up for
saying the dog that is and the buck is
pulled back before Endor ladies Oklahoma
an Oklahoman Oklahoman where am I
Oklahoma sexual is that one of the
characters on your Nashville show I want
to write a song with you well Lex about
us the gay cowboy okay cowboy the gay
cowboys cutting edge character that's
the first gay cowboy ever in primetime
in primetime yes yeah during the lunch
hour it was just littered with them when
I was growing those people on Captain
Kangaroo
right he Ernie and Bert know what they
said all those guys right all right
question I live in an apartment complex
here in the lovely state of Oklahoma
okay yeah the dog barks aggressing for
hours it wakes me up and I have to go to
I have to work at 8 a.m. I filed
complaints after an altercation which I
went out and scream shut your [ __ ]
dog up before I make you shut him up no
that's your opening line it's not or
something along those lines
my must my message has not been heard by
the apartment [ __ ] and she continues to
let the dog out what should I do
sincerely a blue collared working man
just trying to get some [ __ ] sleep
who is he a supe also st. Louis Blues
gave the stars a [ __ ] moly whopping
today I hope you watched it I missed
that well [ __ ] urine you're an Oklahoma
man you know what you need to do take
out your side iron hey hey hey hey yeah
take the [ __ ] dog out the bill Wow
don't even joke about it with rubber
bullets tell you even joke about that
who's your super know you put rubber
bullets in the gun don't and every time
the dog
are talking about a sign of dog law dog
shooting it's a stop and it starts - oh
when I barked and then a little shut up
no you can't do that uh you would get
arrested for that so what I would just
go down I would buy a month's worth of
cube steaks all right why does it does a
dog [ __ ] and piss on the balcony is that
why she's letting it out there cuz
that's gross
I don't know but that is so [ __ ] not
acceptable because you know it's
probably the [ __ ] dog gets up at 4:00
to 5:00 a.m. and keeping her up or him
up so they think oh my god no it's what
you got if you gotta call them or
something always did he say that they're
not paying attention at the lycée it's
not going over well with the people in
the apartment well he has like she just
has a neighbor I can't do I don't think
it's an apartment complex yeah you gotta
say something to the management company
well look there's no [ __ ] way he's
the only person that's annoyed by this
of course I would go around and I would
get a bunch of signatures and then I
would you know try to have everybody all
get together and say that [ __ ] needs to
shut the other [ __ ] oh oh hey oh oh no
god what's so fun how are you it's time
for the run probably to go out speaking
of all that alright will you do that
while I will wrap up the podcast you
know you take Erin I took on a the
Jacksonville this morning that's my uh
it's my excuse all right
well that's going to be the going on
wait so we didn't offer any advice
besides you're a horrible joking advice
of course I just said you get a bunch of
signatures he can't not signatures not
going to do [ __ ] you got to go to the
management company and be like this dog
is barking at 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning every morning oh he said he
already did that
oh and they're not paying attention he
said he's in this [ __ ] not anything
signatures are going to do any
technology like to hear above thoughts
of it oh wait I missed one he said I
have this may I live in apartment
complex for dog barks I've filed
complaint
yeah like nothing's happening
Foxwell oh you have to do this thing I'm
not going to pay my [ __ ] rent there
you go
I'm not paying my rent until you get
this woman to shut this damn dog up cuz
that's not fair
yeah long she's lived there that sounds
like something an older person would do
to don't like put their dog out awesome
balcony and just let it bark all morning
because it probably goes out takes a
piss takes a [ __ ] and then wants to come
inside I mean while the owner has gone
back to sleep
alright well obviously it was joking you
don't shoot the dog no you don't alright
did you make clear here's the other one
alright virtual reality headset [ __ ]
alright I know you hate technology but
would like to hear your opinion on this
my girlfriend half jokingly promised me
a double blow job from my thirtieth
birthday
I do not expect this to happen but I
have been joking with her that the date
is approaching and she should have a
girl lined up etc I have also been
talking about virtual reality / VR
headset as I'm thinking of getting one I
don't know what that is yeah what is she
asked me the other day would I be able
to watch porn through it I said yes she
then said instead of the double bye why
don't you wear the headset and I can
give you normal by while watching a
porno wait what do you what were you
saying about I Oh BJ yeah oh you know
what it was underlined in red so I
couldn't see the bond of I was like what
is this bye oh my god you're really good
yeah and by would actually mean that it
would be a guy in a girl doing this I
wasn't even I was thinking about like
his girlfriend would be like bye because
she was down there with another chick I
am stupid see this people you to be
successful life you're dumb as me she
then she then said instead of a dull
BGA we read this again Wow why don't you
wear a headset and I can give you a
normal BJ while watching a porno why
can't you do that now with a TV easy
because I feel like when they that's
unlike weird
Tron futuristic [ __ ] will you put it on
this opening Pandora's box or is this a
way for VR to be seen as a techy sex toy
you are really asking the wrong person
that question you know bill doesn't know
one look at you in Dublin
myself and some friends will be coming
from bells oh this is I was one okay um
is this the same no I read the ending to
the other one together and it was weird
because the ending was in front of the
other one oh [ __ ] you and [ __ ] everybody
else yeah yeah big it's all funny it's
all fun and games until I stop
podcasting oh oh I've had enough of this
sensitive beep-bop nah I'm not I don't
care it is a slippery slope but I feel
like that could be really kind of cool
does she get to do it too like does she
get to watch some porn while you like go
down on her I'll be really trippy it
would be trippy but the thing is then
then what ends up happening is is then
you end up getting like that dead
disconnect right now you don't want to
do anything that's one of you is wearing
the helmet yes like that it's like
that's weird oh my god I have to like
see you so that's like it's a dangerous
yeah yeah that's like one of those
things like do you think I could do
heroin once and like be alright with
that no I saw something trying to think
where I saw I saw what and in one of
those Asian countries because they're
always ahead of us they have better cell
phones there was a guy trying out like a
virtual reality sex suit which I had a
bit on this thing in like the late 90s
when I first heard that they were going
to do that
and by the way the fact that you haven't
already called me out going like mobile
how did you just stumble upon this I'm
dead honest what I remember I was
waiting for the rest of the story
because I felt like there was it could
have been while I was watching internet
porn probably yeah but they don't have
advertised
advertises for that it was like a story
on the side of the thing they have all
those and how do you know that yeah
right back at you moving right along so
yeah but they don't have our errant ads
like that right that's true well this is
what it was it looked like a [ __ ]
dude but he was like in like a mummy
suit was hilarious Mele was all wrapped
up in toilet paper that's I remember
because it was so horrified it was just
it was one of those things whatever I
was looking at that then came up and I
went yeah right you and it looked like
his hands were to his side he had on the
[ __ ] you know I'm old and I can't see
anymore
those glasses those cataract glass
cataract glasses from the drugstore yeah
so he had on those I think it was all
wrapped up because he didn't want
anybody to see who he was yeah maybe
that's what it was okay and then there
was this thing obviously his dick was in
it oh my god and it's just the same way
your hand would be going like bang bang
bang bang against yourself it was this
thing it was the most [ __ ] up thing
ever would you ever use one of those
fleshpot things you know how porn stars
they get mold or everything is so
[ __ ] gross I mean every guy thinks is
so [ __ ] growing their last time ago I
did somebody's podcast I'm not going to
say who but people who listen to
podcasts know is he had one of those
things in it look like some Jeffrey
Dahmer body I think I know automatically
who your time yeah sitting uh I I don't
think you do because I know who you're
going to guess but it wasn't that person
um it look no it just looked like and it
did you say that it didn't feel like
every it can't feel like a real vagina
obviously but like it washes it III
can't believe that it does like [ __ ]
like that doesn't cause you to either be
like become like a necrophiliac or some
sort of part necrophiliac why would it
make you feel better Ophelia because
you're [ __ ] something that looks
looks like a body part and it's not a
lie well like women have like dildos and
vibrators and stuff and it's like the
same sensation so why wouldn't a one of
the
fleshpot things feel like isn't that
kind of like another Madonna Iggy Pop
thing by looking at it the wrong way
made no I don't think no I don't think
you're looking at it I remember Nia back
in the day don't like the idea of a fake
vagina
oh you don't you're not comfortable
sitting on a table it has a handle on it
and I'm holding it no the thing that's
not your thing you're not into that
feels like Henry portrait of a serial
killer I remember back in the day right
when you actually had to go to a porno
store to get your porn and they had like
you know I was always behind the counter
and they would have [ __ ] up there and it
was like what's in the box
but literally a head in a box the chicks
mouth was like her or like you stick
your dick in it you know like somebody's
gonna buy that yeah it was in like the
same box like a basket ball came in if
someone's gonna take it to grab it by
its [ __ ] ears that are stuck to the
side of its head and they're just going
to go home and [ __ ] a head yeah just a
head now there's no [ __ ] way that
that doesn't [ __ ] you up psychologically
if you do that long enough then you go
out with a real person it's already
annoying that they have to buy it dinner
and that there's a whole body attached
to it and you have to talk to it yeah
they all don't think of just grabbing
you by your ears
water water 100 yes [ __ ] up well I
still feel like going back to the
question I feel like they can experiment
with it like once or twice but it can't
be like a regular thing that they're
doing all the time because then yeah
that'll completely [ __ ] up your sex life
because then you'll just be looking at
everything you do like it's supposed to
be this hyper reality dual reality
virtual it's just not good you know I'm
gonna lay down a let's cook fast-forward
here
okay now so that becomes the thing right
but you know it's gonna mm-hmm
people are going to do it and then it's
going to become is porn stars will be
making all of that [ __ ] money begin
it basically you have a girl
[ __ ] now that probably just feel like
the whole suit especially just gonna be
the whole suit right what are you
talking about I'm talking about like in
the future like when it like everybody
has like a virtual reality sex suit this
will actually help the population
problem right it's a virtual reality sex
suit okay and then porn stars will then
have their likeness they'll do a POV
porn and then they get money and then
you have to like subscribe to that so
you can do like you can do a virtual
reality thing were you with any products
that with like also a cure and then
here's what happens yeah okay who's
going to be the first celebrity that
crosses over and eventually right
because they're sick of doing superhero
movies and they don't want to do the
grunt work of an independent because
like you notice now they're all doing
ads over here back in the day all the
celebrities did ads but they didn't
overseas right remember we used to go
over and we all look at so-and-so doing
a [ __ ] watch thing or look at her
doing this thing but they never do them
here because there was that whole stigma
that if you did a commercial you're a
sellout blah blah whatever the [ __ ] it
was or it's like you're doing a
commercial you're a movie star movie
stars not even on TV forget about doing
an ad now that all went away you know so
I'm saying eventually somebody famous
would do it right you could but ya get a
suit and program it so that you're
having sex with like Lindsay Lohan or
something right and the part of person
the first level will go down ah oh yeah
those reality TV show stars alright you
know when the reality show goes off the
air like Jersey Shore they were all
[ __ ] huge now it's just disappeared
where the [ __ ] are they right mm-hmm
you could probably talk a couple of them
and is doing it right we pitching a show
right now I think or some kind of like
high tech concept where I will probably
make a lot of money that's going to end
up back sounds like a movie it sounds
like like a this is what's going to
happen you're going to have these
self-driving [ __ ] cars you can have
self-driving [ __ ] cars and people
will be laying in them in virtual
reality suits having sex with any famous
person they want to
right and they'll have like because you
don't need a steering wheel of gas or
brake or anything anymore
you're literally like your suit in there
and then when you're done you roll over
from that seat into like another like a
like a freshen up like tub or some [ __ ]
well I think we're totally going in that
direction I think you're right well
we'll see it in the next generation
before it was just yeah the flesh bob
stuff was just the mold of the vagina or
the dick or whatever and then it's going
to be this virtual it'll be super
expensive at first it's going to go into
a completely flat screen TVs first came
out at 14 grant so don't buy the first
virtual reality in the next free virtual
way channel like they come down like 800
bucks at Best Buy then you get them
right
should we figure out how to make this
technology and just like patent it
that's how we'll make our makeup yeah
yeah we're gonna figure out how to do
that I can't even read copy
why not well for calling it that like
that's what's going on I've already
found it right now with these
self-driving cars like the interiors of
cars what they're going to have now
they're going to have office ones
they're going to have sleeper ones
people just want to sleep going to work
they're going to have ones to catch up
on your emails and all that type of [ __ ]
yeah different even those that will be
like the different but the social one
the social and office one all of that
type of all out and then eventually it's
going to be like well why even going to
work down because everything's automated
in those robots right and then one day
the whole [ __ ] thing just turns on us
what if there is a company like in
someplace really random not really
random like a Japan by the way neither
one of us was high right now no not at
all completely that high the middle of
the day never been more sober what if
there was a company somewhere and like I
don't know not Japan but like Eastern
Europe that said we want to do this deal
with you where we have these like sex
dolls with your face loss pounds and
they offered you like what me yeah and
then say an amount of money no no just
to do it oh you can buy a billboard sex
the hall do you realize the phone
I'm going to get and I'm going to have
to retweet now you [ __ ] you're right
oh they're going to be horrifying
hilarious like a bill birthday would you
do yeah they come out of like somewhere
random like you know Norway or just
something or like you know one of the
plays random like Norway along the
doorways that's not random enough like
you know min expand or one of those
[ __ ] places I'm not even saying it
right but just a random little pocket
that was just like you know we have five
million dollars and we want to mix xj
off your face nah no you wouldn't go for
can you imagine that phone call out of
nowhere no no I wouldn't I would know I
can honestly tell you that I would I
know I know you wouldn't
well yeah I would think so how the [ __ ]
did we get all the way over here see
this why I live the questions quite
questions because okay because the
person in their virtual [ __ ] look
when they're by according to you okay I
never claimed to be smart at this
beginning of these podcasts I don't know
I I don't claim to be smart and with
that go [ __ ] yourself
sorry the podcast was so late I was
flying back from Jacksonville as I
mentioned I'm real time several times I
complained about it and I'll be checking
it on you on Thursday I'll see you go
blues